bonsoir de nouvelles mesures ont été
mises en place hier désormais lé
vacanciers belges ne peuvent plus se
rendre où ils le souhaitent en europe
laquelle il prévu aussi pour les belges
qui sont actuellement dans ces zones a
classé rouge
alors effectivement la belgique a
interdit les voyages non essentiels dans
certaines régions d'europe
callac à sion en zone rouge alors parmi
ces zones qui sont passés en rouge
depuis hier on retrouve des régions au
nord par exemple des régions au nord de
l'espagne dont celle de barcelone
il ya également le département de la
mayenne en france et aussi trois cantons
en suisse dont le canton de genève
très concrètement des touristes ont dû
faire demi tour alors qu'ils arrivaient
sur place et d'autres ou tout simplement
annuler leurs vacances
et puis pour ce que vous me demander
pardon à ce que ce qui est ce qui se
passe pour les belges qui sont
actuellement par exemple en zone rouge
comme barcelone eh bien ils doivent se
mettre en quarantaine et devront pardon
se mettre en quarantaine est
obligatoirement se faire dépister une
fois arrivé en belgique et leur que se
passe-t-il pour les personnes qui
souhaitent elles se rendre en belgique
quelles sont les dernières mesures aussi
prise à ces derniers jours pour les
résidents en belgique alors toutes les
personnes qui viennent sur le territoire
belge pour plus de 48 heures doivent
désormais remplir un questionnaire pour
faciliter le traçage en cas de
contamination ils doivent indiquer bien
sûr leurs coordonnées mais également les
pays dans lesquels ils se sont rendus
les deux dernières semaines et ce
questionnaire c'est un questionnaire
qu'il est obligatoire de remplir que
l'on arrive en avion en train ou en
voiture
et puis ce qui se passe en belgique may
face à ce rebond du coc vie de 19 la
belgique fait preuve de fermeté sinon
s'ils ont pu dire par rapport à ses
voisins à bruxelles par exemple port du
masque est obligatoire dans plusieurs
zones de la ville sur la côte et les
plages belges le masque est encore une
fois obligatoire et puis un ouvert la
anvers pardon la ville qui concentre le
taux de contamination le plus élevé un
couvre-feu a même été instauré de 23h
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin cette semaine
merci beaucoup rappellent la blonde
amour journalistes à bruxelles